take a look at this clip from MSNBC and
I would appreciate it if you all would
would listen one day our children's
children will read American history and
can you imagine our reading the James
Madison or Thomas Jefferson tried to
overthrow the government so they could
stay in power that's what we're looking
at we're looking at American history
could you imagine if Thomas Jefferson
tried to overthrow the government I am
shocked everyone knows Thomas Jefferson
stood violently valiantly before the the
people of this great continent and said
all God Save the King all hail the king
we love the crown Britain forever that's
that's exactly the story of the founding
fathers but I just want to add I love
first of all how he's he's so he I'm
sorry man
he's talking about the founding fathers
quite literally over through the
government
and uh yeah but more importantly he's
comparing Donald Trump to the founding
fathers who overthrew a tyrant
for the people and established this
great nation they succeeded
it's kind of a weird perspective it's
like
you're set you're comparing Trump to the
founding fathers right there it's kind
of like okay well that's like a weird
thing to do because people like them and
then being like to overthrow the
government I'm like yeah they succeeded
at doing that so he's obviously in his
defense he's talking about if they'd
invite you know 1811 Thomas Jefferson
was story 1806 or whatever he was still
refusing to let go of power and was like
we are gonna mean we are going to be the
new monarchy
um and so he's referring to that
absolutely not that's what Napoleon
absolutely he's talking about yeah
fabricating context to defend someone
you think that Al Sharpton doesn't know
that Thomas Jefferson was involved in
the American Revolution
is not an actual uh effective thought
leader he is the equivalent of a
political ambulance Chaser right he
shows up to do a couple hits to
fundraise and to make himself feel good
he's not a reliable source for anything
so the fact that this is who they're
triaging with should tell you that he
has no idea what he's talking about and
they are grasping and I'm not saying he
did not know they they were involved in
Revolution I'm taking his statement as
it is I'm I'm establishing no
alternative context like you are doing
The Man compared Donald Trump to
founding fathers who overthrew the
government succeeded to to remove a
tyrant
comparison wrote the document that said
this is why we are overthrowing you this
is why we're Justified this is why we
have no other recourse we are now in
charge we're severing the political
bonds the Declaration of Independence
was literally saying you have no
Authority anymore we're in charge now
well I'm steel Manning his argument for
now it's funny we can laugh at the guy
and be like dumb idiot you didn't know
but like obviously he's talking about if
Thomas Jefferson had overthrown the
American government that makes no sense
there's no context in what he said to
assume he's talking about 1811 or
anything why would you think he's
talking about King George that Thomas
Jefferson didn't overthrow King George
like what you invoke the founding
fathers the obvious example is yes they
overthrew a government they were through
the British government but they didn't
overthrow our government
at the time at the time before they
overthrew it it wasn't not to mention
the critical race Theory argument is
that the founding fathers were wealthy
white slave owners who didn't want to
pay taxes so in order to maintain their
status and power over through the
government that like the point is it is
a stupid thing to say I agree with that
but I stand by and it's out of content I
can't expect anything better what's
funny is MSNBC did they even did they
push back on this at all or were they
just like oh no they're like Reverend Al
sharp and thank you for blessing us with
your presence here today uh we're so
grateful I just will show you a phrase
it can you imagine like let me get my
crystal ball yes I can imagine it would
be first a declaration and then a
revolution and then a free country the
greatest the world has ever known I
can't actually imagine to be fair it was
a revolution then a declaration in in
the French Revolution went haywire they
started a revolution it looked pretty
good and then they wouldn't let go of
the power Robespierre went insane
completely egomaniacal and then so they
started killing each other and then
Napoleon seized it but you know why that
is to be fair repspire was always insane
in the beginning he was really lovable
he was like a brilliant order he was a
lawyer everyone liked him he was the
most level-headed of all of them and
then something that happened I learned
an important lesson from Occupy Wall
Street because I knew some of these far
leftists and uh you know they fought for
free speech in 2011 and then when it
came to the Free Speech arguments in
2018 and 19 I asked I asked these guys
like this one guy I knew I was like how
could you be for free speech back then
and also in your opinion changed and he
laughed and said because you're too
stupid you didn't realize we were using
you we hate liberals when when you
defended our speech it empowered us and
now we want to take yours away from you
because we want power and I was like oh
it makes sense also you know what we
were talking about just before we went
on air we were talking about
libertarianism versus a more ordered
Liberty like a recognition of moral
order that's the biggest difference
between the French Revolution and the
American Revolution the American
Revolution was based I know this is
really historically nerdy was based on
this idea that there was some
fundamental objective truth that we
didn't just determine as as populism
right and the French Revolution chose
libertarianism instead so we ordered our
constitution on original Justice which
is like judeo-christian values in the
French Revolution didn't they ordered it
as Freedom as the ultimate end whereas
we viewed Freedom as the means of
something greater and the the I think
the one of the big differences a
catalyst and one of the principal
catalysts for the French Revolution was
economics
people were starving there was famine
and so you had all these French people
being like don't know don't care I'm
angry and that just led to beheadings
and other chaos whereas in the United
States it was consistent oppressive
actions by the crown and things like no
representation in government and the the
founding fathers and many of the state
leaders would repeatedly petition the
crown for things that made more sense on
our behalf and they would just say no
screw off over and over again so the
revolutionary period was actually about
20 years long and the Declaration of
Independence was way later on in that
whole period that's an interesting point
about the secularism of the French
Revolution it's interesting I haven't
really thought much about it but that
the American Revolution was like I don't
know if it's a Christian Revolution they
put God in in a lot of writings than the
the French Revolution is all about like
do away with the old God create a new
religion create a new calendar you know
we don't want to adhere to these oldies
I saw an interesting video where uh some
conservative dude was doing one of those
gotcha videos of stupid people in Times
Square
and he asked what year did America gain
its independence and I thought that
question was really really funny because
even he did not know the answer
because what what year was it anybody
have a guess
81 1781 are you talking about
technically because I mean if you want
to be real philosophical about this you
could argue that in some ways where it's
a continuous battle that's ongoing
forever 2023 be uh yeah I mean that's
kind of like a lame answer I actually
don't know the year are you talking
about like when the Constitution
Revolution ended the surrender of
Cornwallis
was that 81 did they fight yeah 81 81 at
Yorktown so that was uh
eight uh
no wait that's the wrong one
uh 1781.
so they announced it in 76. so you can
make the argument result we had our
independence in 1776 but I disagree uh
declaring it didn't change the fact the
crown asserted their Right and started
shooting at Americans to and actually
controlled a bunch of cities and
occupied places so we did not have it it
wasn't until Cornwallis surrendered that
we actually gained it so 1781 but I
think it's funny because they're like
what year was it and supposed to be 1776
it's like No actually that's when you
know they started sending the troops
right granted they were already sending
in the troops to be fair and that's kind
of a catalyst for it but uh yeah you
know I think I think what happened right
after is what's interesting because we
didn't have the Constitution for a while
after right we had instead with the
Articles of Confederation and that was
structured on more of a Libertarian
basis and it resulted in chaos and they
realized that we couldn't order a
society along those lines so we had to
we had to use the Constitution to
reorder it along James Madison's
viewpoints which were more ordered
Liberty I think there is something you
said for the question of you know people
think it's 1776 because they think when
you declared that you were independent
you had Independence because you have oh
well you claimed it you claimed it
you're aware that you want these things
but I think it is important to
underscore that you actually had to
fight for it you have to you have to
keep this going right you can seed
grounded a republic if you can keep it
yeah to be fair I was even wrong about
that the American Revolution officially
ended September 3rd 1783 with the
signing of the Treaty of Paris
Cornwallis has surrendered in 81 ended
any chance of the British actually being
able to win a war and so from that point
on there was still conflict and
occupation but then the treaty was
signed in 1783. that's crazy right yeah
like the American Revolution took place
over 20 some odd years you could have
been born a couple years after the start
of this period and then fought in the
War you know like your whole life was
hearing about all this revolutionary
stuff I mean that's true of anyone who
deployed to Afghanistan right I knew
people who were in kindergarten after
some people were born after 9 11 and
ended up serving in Afghanistan so these
things yeah that's trippy it is trippy
right yeah that makes me so mad the
Afghanistan stuff because I I have been
thinking a lot about the draft we talked
about the draft a few days ago and how
there was call people were talking about
it and it's like the military numbers
aren't doing very well
because they sent us into that occupying
war in the Middle East in Afghanistan
and then Iraq and Libya we conquered
Iraq and then we conquered Libya and
people are getting pissed off that
Russia wants to conquer a trade Port
right on its border like you
kidding me we took Libya we're in
control of Libya right now we own Libya
like this is the grossest and I
mean we need to inspire our military
that's what bothers me is that the
demoralization in the military I don't
think we own Libya
yeah and now there's a slave trade
instead of osprey Global did we set up
Sydney blumenthal's Osprey Global
Solutions there for Libya for a while
has been ruled by like random try
warring tribes since the fall of Gaddafi
yeah it's basically an American puppet
state my problem wasn't that we went
into Afghanistan I think that was
perfectly morally Justified after we had
been attacked on 9 11 my problem was how
they handled it like you go into a war
you have
um terms of Engagement that allow our
fighting men and women to win and you
actually have a plan for victory and you
have an objective that is Victory like
you get in you do your thing you get out
like don't drag it on forever there was
there was no reason to go into
Afghanistan
if the argument is that we should have
gone to Afghanistan because some of the
911 hijackers were Afghani it's like
what about Egypt Taliban yeah but what
about Egypt or Pakistan or Saudi Arabia
I mean they're all Saudi Arabia got sued
I think over 9 11. I'm not going to get
in the whole uh history of that because
there's too many gaps in my knowledge
but it wasn't like it was just the
Taliban that did it Osama Bin Laden was
hiding in Pakistan there was uh funding
coming from various sources in various
Middle Eastern countries some of the
hijackers were Egyptian we didn't go and
invade those countries I don't disagree
with that I think that that Taliban was
giving safe passage to Osama Bin Laden
so you you can go back and make that
argument I'm not especially against
Saudi Arabia I think that they were
certainly not held accountable because
they were a territorial Ally if you will
I think part but I do think 15 were
citizens of Saudi Arabia yeah two were
from the Emirates one was from Egypt and
one was from Lebanon most of them were
from Saudi Arabia and we're just like
nah that's cool sad he's like we're all
right with you yeah I think part of the
problem is that war that we pretended
was in a war but obviously was a war
never ended right now I can tell you
people born after it deployed to
Afghanistan but then the Biden
Administration said we want to pull out
on September 11th to have some symbolic
win for our Administration we also how
that went like there is something
fundamentally wrong and I think to your
point uh you know
I have family members and I know people
who are part of the military and there
is an energy of discouragement but also
I don't think our culture knows totally
how to uh handle our military right I
mean I think a lot of us are anti-war
and I think that's probably good on the
other hand where do you put in people
who go into military service for
honorable reasons how do you reconcile
both things at once I'd like to build
solar-powered water condensation all
over the planet like if we could have
peacekeeping missions with our troops
and our military and actually
reducions is like this is actually
something else we call it peacekeeping
business
Vietnam you know this is cool advice
what they do is they build these there's
a bunch of different ways you can do it
but they have these big white
plastic or something you know Carbon
structures that are flat up top and then
slowly as they get lower become rounded
and funneled and what happens is the
condensation sticks to it and the water
pours down and it fills up fresh water
by the morning you can actually have
them go underground so the air goes in
goes down underground and cools way down
underground and then you can have like
solar panels that are like heating
panels or cooling panels underground
that are connected to the solar up top
so it super cools the the gas
underground we got a lot of work that's
cool stuff the the reason I I like to
elaborate on the DS because they're
really awesome stuff we could be doing
but instead we just keep we just seem to
be blowing people up all over all over
the world that's what our money is good
for gender studies in Pakistan LK 99
that's room temperature superconductor
did you guys hear about that it's going
to change the entire Computing industry
Computing industry bro you have no idea
dude I have no idea it's like I'm that's
why no one's standing on the president I
love science I have to say I feel like I
come on this show and you guys teach me
so much so superconductors where you can
pass a lot of electricity through
without losing it uh you need to be they
need to be really cold but these can be
done at near room temperature apparently
proposed ambulance the claim is and
they're being reproduced superconductors
zero resistance transfer of electricity
we lose energy as it's transferred
around uh there's heat losses a bunch of
loss with the superconductor you don't
have that there's a lot of things you
can do they do super super conductor
levitation they'd be able to do like
maglev trains on the cheap it would
completely change Computing it would
completely change batteries it would uh
uh what people are claiming is that it
will make the world like a Sci-Fi
reality like this is a major
breakthrough on par with the the
discovery of the charged electromagnetic
spectrum yeah and because such
nobody believes it and they're waiting
for replication because room temperature
superconductors is going to like
yeah it's gonna be like sci-fi I heard
that they're they're replicating it now
and this with like deep fakes and with
obviously the internet all these weird
Technologies of like I'm really gonna be
able to imagine something and then see
it like with the neural net I I we're
entering like another time I think
that's the craziest things these these
uh Revolutions in Technologies
evolutions of technology I should say
are happening faster than ever before so
my thought is that we're just you we're
going to evolve into another species but
what do you think Liz like did you get a
brain chip no not right away never Elon
said that he would get one well I hope
he has a great time no thank you if most
people will get it if I see like
hundreds of thousands of young people in
high school getting it and just like
blowing test scores out of the water
learning much as languages becoming
really good at Athletics I would
consider it but I would rather have
something non-invasive like a helmet or
something like so you like the augmented
reality glasses I like you know anybody
who doesn't have a cell phone yeah
how many people do you know don't have
cell phones like five because I know
people who live off the grid right I
don't know anybody that doesn't have a
cell phone after like older than High
School our cell phones CIA tracking
devices oh certainly all your
information is tracked by any
intelligence agency around the world who
wants it so
conservatives know full well the Deep
state is tracking literally everything
they do every website they go to every
picture they look at every naughty thing
they do on the internet and they don't
care and they would then say well I'm
not getting the brain chip and it's like
oh please dude 10 years you'll all be
chipped here's here's where I think it's
different because when Apple what's
Apple's thing that's coming out that
augmented reality goggles that he just
announced a couple months ago there was
an engineer that worked on that who did
a thread on Twitter right after it was
announced who said I worked on part of
this as it was going I don't work there
anymore a lot of it's under NDA and he
was bragging he was proud of having
worked on it he was he was talking about
how what they wanted to teach it to do
was anticipate what you want so that you
could uh so they could offer you things
as you're going and I thought well that
doesn't sound cool to me that sounds
like the ability to manipulate because
if you get used to them anticipating
then they could plant ideas that are
just like that could control your
movements I think that's very different
than a cell phone because you're not
it's not integrated into your
Consciousness even like I have myself in
my hand all the time obviously like
we're all obsessed with it but it's not
part of my decision making process
because it hasn't been like it hasn't
been merged with my Consciousness like
that's really funny
to go without your cell phone so the one
fair point I'll make is there's a
difference between holding something in
your hand and and having a surgery right
my people don't want to do surgery but
cell phones
changed everything before we had the
iPhone if you wanted to go on the
internet it was you'd go out and hang
out with your friends then be like I
when you get home I'll see what's
happening online then you'd go out and
hang out with your friends then come
home once I thought the iPhone came out
and people had this was like the the
expansion the explosion into 24 7 web
now you were on Facebook non-stop all
day every day a dramatic difference yeah
I don't disagree with that so our
conscious are our our Consciousness has
merged with the internet at this point
your phone is always with you and now
look I'm wearing a smart watch that
vibrates when someone tweets at me I
think the weird thing is it doesn't
actually do that because I blocked that
but like I get text messages your watch
is just like constantly going off right
no I think part of it is you'll start to
see a separation of societies right like
you asked me who do I know who doesn't
have cell phones and like they are all
off the grid mountain people who chose
to live that way and know they're going
without some Modern conveniences for
that reason I think I mean like you're a
young parent there will be parents who
opt to give their kid uh an Instagram
profile and an iPad really early on and
then there will be parents who say I'm
gonna hold out for as long as I possibly
can I think you will see a clear
difference in these things and maybe
we'll have data to say like hey these
people are benefiting here's here's
what's happening because that because
again technology is moving so quickly
we're able to track things better than
ever before on the other hand I think
culturally will just split apart I think
people have like the mountain people and
the tech people you mentioned before the
show like shared morality how it's such
an important part of a cohesive
government for instance the United
States government had like a shared kind
of a almost an authoritarian morality to
it but so I see this technology in this
augmented reality brainship lifestyle is
like a fast track to a shared morality
they can tell us what we think or they
can make us believe a certain thing and
it could be good could be bad but like
do you think that it's even possible to
get humans to come together and begin to
share numerality without using like this
this mind meld Tech this internet I mean
I'm first of all I didn't say the word
authoritarian when it came to me that
was me that was you
um
I I wouldn't I just don't think it's an
accurate word to describe what I'm
talking about so
um
I think that cell phones have connected
us in a way like I'm grateful for my
cell phone I also see like the problems
that it has wrought like I actually
think the point that Tim was making is a
good is a good argument for my point
like Tick Tock has changed the minds and
I don't mean like change the thought
like change the ideological Minds like
it has changed the brains of gen Z and
not in a good way it should be an
argument probably pushing further away
from augmented reality because already
just with disattached phones we've
wrecked a generation with that
um I think in your point is a point that
I make a lot that indoctrination is not
inherently immoral it's what's being
indoctrinated that determines whether
it's good or bad right like our
education system right now indoctrinates
children in like anti-American
anti-christian pro-marxist values and
that's wrong but it's not because this
school is being used for indoctrination
indoctrination is morally neutral we
actually should be using the education
system for indoctrination we should just
be indoctrinating children in what's
good and right and true we should be
indoctrinating them in American Civic
values and in Christian virtues even if
they're not practicing religious people
our nation is built like our entire
legal structure is built on the on on
judeo-christian values right you can't
murder someone why because that person's
made in the image and likeness of God
like that's the only thing that sets us
apart from animals so I think we should
be using venues that we have for
indoctrination we just have to be
smarter than the left and when's the
last time that you can point to
a conservative a republican politician
an institution that's actually
controlled by the right the rights
stopped fighting for those like 50 years
ago so it's just controlled by the left
so yeah they're forming the minds and
the ideologies of all these young people
it's terrible but it is changing with
the Bud Light for instance the new the
news that just came out they lost 400
million dollars or whatever there's a
big cultural shift sound of Freedom
obviously thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time